[Musique]
c'est un petit bonheur s qui si vous
avez déjà essayer de reconquérir une ex
dit la vérité franchement et la voilà
jamais vous quand on a eu fini c'est
quand c'est fini c'est à marennes bas
mais quand c'est fini vous êtes déjà
marié avec voilà j'anticipe à william
est serré lui se marient d'abord il
casse après vous elle rime à la gelée
sortie combien de ma fille laquelle j'ai
mal trois ans il sortait quand même neuf
dans sa nuit son nom colle je suis
content qu'il est là bon on s'en fout
les extraits bien
alex je suis papa pas énormément mais
genre combien ces 50 entre 50 et 100
entre cinq et dix autres
cent et deux touchés mais ça marche qui
boucla mais c'est vrai quoi plus de 100
me à lille c'est quand même sympa de
votre ex laquelle à laquelle ces règles
seront désormais la dernière est que
c'est pas la soeur à kader n'ont jamais
là sera khadr a d'accord et c'est qui
votre action elle s'appelle la dernière
la dernière je ne reviens pas isabelle
non sous qaïda sous qaïda et ben ouais
bon brunes ou blondes brunes
il est là encore un mot est assez qu'on
va voir à quel moment je suis resté deux
heures je suis resté je suis resté
pendant longtemps quand même avec l
major pour longtemps pour moi après que
vous seriez pas combien un an à wayne
rooney
vous avez déjà essayé de conquérir un ex
way gérer c'est une fois et ça n'a pas
marché donc je reste à jamais rester qui
passa par son père vous ne connaissez
pas c'est par son père
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui j'appelle vous avez déjà essayer de
reconquérir un ex vivant où tous
[Musique]
alors oui quand j'avais quand j'avais 16
ans je sortais avec un basketteur
domaine 95 avait dit que je vous avoue
n'avoir pas dépasser mon paquet en est
dit inversément réclamant panier oui ça
ça pouvait faire mais pas plus que je
voulais passer mon bac à 20 voyages et
bienvenue des années après il m'a dit
qu'elle quelles conneries que j'ai pas
attendu non cergy étaient comestibles
très longtemps je n'ai rien on le sait
voilà les vraies cibles merci et je vois
mal que bien que le film soit un
partenariat europe 1 en un avis le plus
grand bien nous ce matin sur wii est
attendu il semble bien pourtant ça
prouve a dû bien défendre et je sais que
sur également radio cocktail
ils ont également voulu radio cocktail
europe 1 ils se tirent la bourre amca
quand même faut saluer vous oui j'ai une
très bonne technique pour reconquérir
les axes c'est qu'en fait tu le payes
jeu qu'on paie je paye
[Rires]
[Musique]
messi
seul désir campait je m'installais
devant chez elle sur le pas de la porte
après on a une semaine ou quinze jours à
la fin elle a fait la police ou encore
récent oui en a qui ont appelé la police
ce que je bougeais pas ça s'appelle du
harcèlement se voit l'euro ou alors
escaladé par les fenêtres aussi j'étais
elle a adoré la somme près n'a jamais
marché
mais il faut comprendre mais je
comprends par contre les filles combien
de fois au poste
je suis en a qui ont appelé la police
c'est vrai mais bon je sais bien
terminée beaucoup de problème entre moi
et mes problèmes principaux c'est avec
les ex les garçons les ex de mérina moi
à oui pourquoi
et bien là là j'ai été attaqué une fois
joyeux ailleurs il ya une bagarre il ya
une bagarre ya une bagarre à l'opéra
alors il ya une bagarre à ses décors non
alors là on est en 1982
1981 le hockey way et j'arrive en fait
moi je venais gentiment je vais
d'ailleurs voir gentiment j'arrive et je
commence à faire le code et je vois un
gars qui me saute dessus mis
littéralement et le gars me prend par le
col il me fait descendre c'est dans
paris v la butte montmartre il me fait
descendre en malpas gants comme ça
pendant trente mètres et ils me jettent
ils me jettent dans la vitrine d'un
primeur alors ouais et le gaillard il
était tard le soir mais alors j'ai tout
lu dans l'époque dans les brouillards il
m'a jetée dans les pêches et les
brugnons tous âges en avait partout et
il avait une bague avec une tête de mort
et un clou dans l'eau comme ça on l'a
levé il m'a dit t'es mort
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il m'a dit démarre alors juste à ce
moment là mais c'est miracle la fille
est arrivée n'ont appris et la calmer
elle a pris une pastèque et lui a cassé
sur la gueule et j'ai encore la vision
du cloud n'en prenne mon front non mais
un coup comme ça on va bien sûr mais des
menus si le garçon ces conflits ont
éclaté dans un groupe de rock
cela va très très bas et franchement
elle
bush sur l on est d'accord tu es là le
mec de dire j'ai failli mourir snobé
l'histoire jouer jouer sur cap l'index
qui essaie de reprendre avec vous bah
non c'est moi qui a pas lâchés pendant
les années la jambe de plus à oui c'est
vrai sailly fackeure vous êtes un nom là
j'en ai plusieurs parce que c'est
normalement complices vous avez bien
raison c'est la technique castaldi il a
raison mais la raison il est comme ça
aussi alors